it's easy to be calm and mindful when
you're in a cave but how do you do it in
the world and how do you do it under
extreme duress
that's what reveals character as a kid I
was really sort of naturally insecure
until I discovered drugs and alcohol and
that was like the miracle self that
solved every problem that up to that
point I didn't know that I had
[Music]
I was a pretty broken guy it was a it
was a pretty dire dark scenario I woke
up one day hungover and decided I'm
finally ready to do something about this
and went off to rehab and I was able to
actually grab onto that rope and start
doing that interior work that was my
first introduction to meditation I had
this moment walking up these steps late
one night where I had to pause and I
tightness in my chest and sweat on my
brow and really fear in my heart that I
was on the precipice of a very serious
heart issue and it scared me and that
began the process of me once again
reconfiguring my life I became amazed at
how resilient the human body is because
for so many years I had beaten myself up
with drugs and alcohol and fast food and
workaholism you know you name it and I
realized that if my body could bounce
back this quickly from all the terrible
treatment that I've given it for most of
my life like what is it really capable
of that's what introduced me to Ultraman
for people that don't know it's a double
Ironman distance triathlon 320 miles
that over a three-day period
circumnavigates the entire Big Island of
Hawaii it's insane
it's very easy to get freaked out and
think oh my gosh I can't do this Who am
I kidding or this is too painful I want
to just stop so a race like Ultraman
it's crucial to be able to anchor
yourself in the present moment you have
to be able to let go of what just
happened and what is in your near future
and focus on what is happening right now
and the more you can do that then all of
that fear kind of evaporates your
thinking mind is that pesky guy on your
shoulder who's trying to talk you out of
everything and so the trick becomes
learning how to tap into a higher state
of awareness so that you can be mindful
and you can be present and that's the
place you want to be in as an athlete
because that's when you're completely
centered and focused and I will say in
all honesty that headspace has been
really great for helping me have a
consistent approach to my practice
because it is right on my phone and I
put it down in the dock at the bottom
it's a constant reminder and it's so
easily accessible to be able to do it
wherever you find yourself for somebody
who is beginning to meditate five
minutes might seem like an eternity and
that's what I experienced during this
training like I could get to a place
where a seven hour ride didn't feel like
that long and that's really a mental
practice yes there's physical discomfort
and the training is athletic and
physical but truly a race like Ultraman
all comes down to your mental emotional
and spiritual state and that is really
the defining characteristic that would
define any any champion in that regard
you
you